[Music]
suspiria
is a 2018 italian american horror
based on the 1977 film of the same name
similar to the original there's a lot to
unpack from its ending
and throughout this video i'll be
discussing the movie in full detail
there will be heavy spoilers so it may
be worth skipping this for now if you
want to go into the film
with fresh eyes with that out the way
i'm definition
and i ruin the movie so you don't have
to the story
suspiria is told in six separate packs
the initial one 1977 follows patricia
played by chloe grace moretz as she
visits her psychiatrist to inform him
that the prestigious dance school
the marcos academy that she studies at
is ran by a coven of witches
the psychiatrist named joseph klemperer
initially dismisses this as delusion
but when the young girl goes missing his
suspicions arise
it's at this point that we are
introduced to susie played by dakota
johnson
susie quickly catches the eye of company
director madame blanc
and joins the academy strange
occurrences begin to happen
such as a student named olga becoming
trapped in a room of mirrors
after accusing blanc of being a witch
during a rehearsal
blanc resumed the rehearsal but
inflicted a power over susie's dance
moves that had huge consequences
suzy quickly becomes the protege of
madame blanc and she appoints the new
student to lead their production of valk
this arouses suspicion from the other
dancers and
sarah who is also a student at the
academy begins to investigate the
witches on a deeper level
she believes that susie may be in
collusion with them so sneaks off into
the catacombs of the school on the night
of the performance
down in the dark she discovers the body
of patricia and is confronted by the
matrons from the school
sarah breaks her leg trying to escape
but makes it back in time to perform
in the production of bulk joseph who is
attending the show and notices that
sarah and susie's eyes have both changed
color which confirms his suspicions that
patricia was telling the truth
this also teases that suzy may indeed be
working with the witches
during this part of the movie joseph
encounters his long
thought dead wife she informs him that
during the nazi uprising of the second
world war
she faked her own death and fled to
zurich the two walk and talk until
joseph realizes that he has been tricked
and led to the marcos academy one of the
matrons has merely been posing as his
wife and the witches incapacitate and
capture him
leaving him in a chamber it's at this
point that susie returns to the school
and we get a full introduction to mother
helena
marcos we learn that susie has been
chosen as the new vessel for mother
marcos who has outgrown her current form
several dancers show up to perform a
ritual but things go awry when susie
reveals her true plan
susie is so skilled because she is
actually mother suspirium
there to claim the academy and eradicate
mother marcos
she kills marcos and most of the other
matrons except blanc
blanc is discovered the next day alive
but heavily wounded
during the onslaught it's revealed that
three of the matrons are in fact
zara patricia and olga and each one of
them pleads for death
due to the control and enslavement that
they have been placed in
susie obliges them and begins a dance
that grants her control of the academy
she spares joseph and meets him in his
office the next day where she confirms
that his wife is in fact dead
and was killed whilst at a concentration
camp susie erases all of his memories
and leaves ending the film to me the
biggest signify behind the film's
meaning
is its time saying the movie is set
amidst the cold war but still has a lot
of call backs to the one that preceded
it
the most glaring of these are the
metaphors for the holocaust
if viewed correctly the academy has a
lot of similarities to concentration
camps
they are overseen by cold and ruthless
people and
kill and enslave those who speak up or
do not work to the satisfaction of the
overseers
susie is an outsider that comes in and
liberates those within much in the same
way that allies did
and her home of america could be seen as
the biggest confirmation of this theory
the holocaust is something that should
never be forgotten and if we no longer
remember the atrocities that happened
there then we could be doomed to repeat
them
there is a climate of racism that exists
within modern culture that is currently
at boiling point and we must look at
examples such as the concentration camps
as reminders of this
this is why joseph's amnesia is so
tragic
he like many during the period lost
loved ones but has now been forced to
forget the horrendous things that
happened so he can no longer go
forth and educate those on the witches
leaving the rest of the world blind to
what could happen
blanc can also be used as a metaphor for
those who escape persecution from the
allies
several nazis who participated at the
concentration camps were never properly
prosecuted and blanc could be a somber
reminder that sometimes justice is not
served
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and there's definitely a lot
to take from it so i could be completely
wrong
just let me know if you have a different
interpretation in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
the ending of halloween which is linked
at the end of this one
this is a channel for people who are mad
about movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you